- La bannière Loblaw, qui
comprend les épiceries Provigo
et Maxi, fixe les prix jusqu'au
31 janvier sur plus de 1500
produits de sa marque maison
"Sans Nom" qu'on peut
reconnaître dans les
supermarchés grâce
à son étiquette jaune.
- Je tro- Je tro- Je trouve quee
nouvelle, en fait. Je trouve
que c'est un prix, en fait,
qui ne devrait pas trop varier
en général, question que
c'est quand même la marque
de base, on s'entend.
- Habituellement, on prend
des trucs plus bio, et tout ça,
donc ça nous affecte un peu
moins.
- On ne sait jamais, quand on va
faire l'épicerie, si le prix a
ou... diminué, c'est
sûr que ça ne sera pas le cas.
- Alors que le prix des aliments
connaît une hausse de 9,7 %
depuis l'année dernière,un gel t
aider davantage les ménages
à s'y retrouver, selon Option
Consommateurs.
SYLVIE DE BELLEFEUILLE, avocate
chez Option Consommateurs
- Un gel, c'est mieux qu'une
augmentation. On va prendre
ce qu'on peut. L'impact dépend
toujours, dans le fond
du pouvoir d'achat des gens.
- Oui, il y a un coup
de marketing, ça, il y a
ute.
- Et selon le professeur
de marketing, Jacques Nantel,
Loblaw calcule perdre un peu
d'argent sur chacun deses produt
la "Sans Nom", mais espère,
en bout de ligne, déplacer de
la clientèle vers ses magasins.
JACQUES NANTEL, prof. émérite
en marketing à HEC Montréal
- Ce que l'on vise à faire,
c'est... c'est de changer les
comportements des consommateurs.
t dit, consommateurs,
si vous voulez pouvoir avoir
un peu plus d'argent dans
vos poches, bien vous allez
devoir changer vos habitudes.
- Avant Loblaw, d'autres
épiciers comme la chaîne de
supermarchés française Carrefour
et la  branche américaine
de la codl ont
tout deux respectivement
gelé et baissé le prix sur
une centaine de lets
pour une période déterminée.
Et au Québec, la compagnie
Métro a annoncé aujourd'hui
qu'elle l sur le prix
de certains produits de marques
privées et nationales
du 1er novembre au 5 février.
Ici Gabrielle Proulx,
Radio-Canada, Mon